I tell you I am just the luckiest yeah I
can't believe I'm walking out of the
order Hall with the
order and living in the coolest town in
the whole world Beacon
Town what is this
thing it looks kind of okay actually it
looks really
cool the Warriors of the whispering
Mountain call me the stab Walker but you
may call me Jack this is
nurm he's the genius behind all of our
fine
Maps look who it is Jesse leader of
Beacon town and my sworn rival I've
never met her before right no the
world's a lot bigger than you think it
is Jesse there she is
incredible statues My Sword I can I can
almost reach it don't
worry I've got
it the town's in danger I stopped it for
now but I think this can help me fix it
permanently it's time to charart a cord
for Doom
SE shut up nurm it's an awesome
name